in this video you're going to learn how
to write the quadratic equation of a
parabola when you're given the two x
intercepts and another point on the
graph so we're going to be working with
this intercept form right here which you
can see is like a factored form and if
we want to graph this just to get a feel
for what it looks like we can see it's
crossing here at -20 on the
xaxis and also at 40 so those are two x
intercepts and we know it's going
through the point
01 now we know parabas they're symmetric
right so we can find the midline if we
wanted here 1 2 3 4 5 6 so halfway would
be right here that's our axis of
symmetry so our graph would look
something
roughly like this okay but what we want
to do is we want to get the equation so
what we're going to do is we're going to
substitute in our 2 x intercepts for p
and Q so the way that looks is y = a * x
- -2 * x - pos4 and when you subtract
it's like adding the opposite so this is
really like x + 2 x - 4 some students
kind of remember it's like the opposite
see this is negative -2 but this is
positive two this is positive4 this is
like a ne4 but we need to find out what
this a value is the a represents like
the stretch or the shrink or the
reflection and the way that we do that
is we use another point on the graph not
one of the X intercepts but an
additional Point that's given here which
is the point 0 1 now you can see 0 is X
And1 is y so if we substitute those
values into our equation here for X and
Y we can solve for a so this is going to
come out to let's see -1 = a * 2 *
-4 which this is -8 *
a divide both sides by8 to get the a by
itself and you can see that uh a is
coming out to positive 1/8 because the
two negatives cancel and what we can do
is we can take this 1/8 put it back into
our equation for a and we've got it so
it should look something
like this right here and this is our
intercept form now if you want to you
can multiply these two binomials uh
together and then go ahead and multiply
everything then by 1/8 and you can put
it into the standard form but for right
now let's just leave it in the intercept
form and you got it if you want to see
another example to test yourself and get
some more practice follow me over to
that video I did right there and we'll
get some more practice I'll see you
there